لحتى الان ما عرفت شيء الا عن زوجتي
اولادي بعرف شي عنهم الى اكثر من شهر ونص
مصاب بعرف شي عن
اودي انا اياد هشام شحاد المصري ووالد
الطفل محمد
المصري كانت عند بنت بنتي تعبت وراحت على
النصر قعدت محاصرين في النصر شهر
رجعت على بعد ما هذا طلعنا محاصرين بواسطه
الصليب الاحمر يومين قعدت يعني لسه يا
دوبني بشوف اودي بعد غياب شهر في
النصر يومين قعدت اللي صارت ه
الهوايه
صرت تهبنا من شغلنا بجوزي وابني ما عرفتش
اولاد الباقيين وين راحوا وين
اجوا
انا كنت بنفس الوقت انا بالنسبه لمحمد انه
انا مصاب نفس القصه وانا وقفت حالي على
العلاج وظليت ني اجري معاه انا مصاب في
مقعدي تي وفي رجلي وفي جنبي هان كل هذه بس
الحمد لله تحسنت اموري بس المشكله انه
محمد عندي انا لما بشيله وبعينه باموره
صعبه صعبه ما صدقت التقي بامه بالصدفه
التقيت في امه بقولها وين الاولاد بتقوللي
ما بعرف عن الاولاد
بتص
اول شيء خبطوا في المدرسه اللي جابنا بعد
ما خبطوا اوزعنا شيء في شقه واشي في شقه
ثانيه وهم اولادي خمسه وبعديه ماعرفتش شيء
عنهم ولا حاجه انا دورت وصرت اجري من هان
لمكان لمكان اني حتى اني الاقي ولد من
اولادي يسعف اخوهم م لقت وكنت انا
لحالي الاولاد اللي هو بلال وهشام وعبد
وانس عبود وانس واولادي انا ما ب ما في
صوره لهم يعني اللي اعرف عليها لانه لا
معي جوال ولا اتصال ولا ولا شيء طلعنا
بقول لك
حافين
مالك عن رجلي ط ما فيش
علاج فيش
علاجات محمد ابني هذا كان اللقب تبعه
الوحش دون عن اخوته
يعني عارفه ايش معنى الوحش يعني هو اللي
بيحمل وه اللي بينزل الان خلص اللقب
تبعه اللي بقدر
اقوله انا موجود الان في المستشفى
الاوروبي ما بعرف عنهم اللي بعرف عنهم انا
موجود في المستشفى يجي يبلغني لاني ما
عندي اي وسيله اتصال
لهم انا 60 من يوم ما شفتش حتى الان من
يوم الصف ما شفتهم ارم ولا شفتهم بالمره
الحصار الحصار بالشمال وخايفين وبدي اشوف
فيش حدا يطلبنا
عنهم انا اسمي حلا عرفات معروف عمري 13
سنه انا حوضي مكسور الحوض مع الفك مكسوره
ورجلي اليمين بلاتين وانا حيلتي من دهوري
انا س 24
ساعه مش خواتي
واخواتي اخواتي وابوي وامه كلهم مش
الدار انا مريم معروف انا عمه المصابات
حلا ونور بدهم اهاليهم بدهم امهم وابوهم
يكونوا جنبهم دائما بيبكوا بالليل ما
بيناموا من الوجع انا طلعنا
ب احداث الاندونيسي الان ما بنعرف اي شي
عن اهلي في الشمال تح والله
نتحرك والله بطلع والله انا زهقان والله
زهقان من
[تصفيق]
الحياه